[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous
parlais de mon coup de cœur cinéma c'est
le film qui veut la peau de Roger Rabbit
réalisé par Robert Zemeckis en 1988 la
spécificité de ce film c'est que c'est
le premier à utiliser la prise de vue
réelle et le dessin animé comme le fera
plus tard Space Jam ou Arthur et les
Minimoys par exemple et la force de
Robert Zemeckis c'est d'arriver à rendre
le cartoon cartoonk mais de rendre aussi
la prise de vue réelle donc le film avec
les acteurs vraiment tout aussi
cartoonesque en terme de rythme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un détective privé
spécialiste dans les affaires de toune
les toons c'est les petits dessins
animés les petits personnages qui va
devoir protéger la grande star du
cartoon le lapin Roger Rabbit c'est
plein d'humour c'est plein de références
à ceux qui aiment les cartoon des années
80 en termes de réalisation c'est aussi
très original avec ce procédé cartoon
vidéo c'est quand même réalisé par
Robert Zemeckis celui qui a fait
redoudre le futur et Forrest Gump donc
c'est quelqu'un qui qui sait s'y faire
dans le cinéma on rit c'est pour tous
les âges pour les parents pour les
enfants tout le monde il trouvera son
bonheur je vous conseille de voir qui
veut la peau de Roger Rabbit de Robert
Zemeckis
[Musique]